je vous propose de passer la parole à
notre rapporteur qui vous présente un
peu l'esprit et pillant et après chacun
de vous pour ac2 privé environ une une
dizaine de minutes en étant relativement
précis concis et ensuite dans un second
temps je passerai la parole la mecque
collègue sénatrice et les sénateurs qui
sont là et certains d'autres en présent
et qu'il y aura un échange entre entre
nous c'est le rapporteur merci monsieur
le président écoutez merci d'abord
d'être venus et ont participé à cette
table ronde qui pour nous est importante
on a souhaité dissocier la problématique
santé mentale de la problématique santé
en général à travers de tables rondes
comme l'expliqué le président parce
qu'on sent bien qu'il ya un sujet
spécifique autour de la santé
psychologique qui s'exprime de manière
très fort ces dernières semaines et ces
derniers mois
j'avoue en toute modestie mais je pense
qu'un constat peu près partager c'est
une problématique que nous connaissons
mal est relativement peu été étudiés de
notre part ici au sénat et donc on est
très bien sûr en attente de ce que vous
pouvez nous dire
cet après midi pour résumer en
grossièrement un petit peu les trois
domaines de d'investigation qui sont les
nôtres avant de venir sur les trois
domaines d'investigation je faire un un
préalable mais qui est important c'est à
dire corps dans le cadre de cette
mission on est parti avec une idée que
la crise du coville avait fait émerger
des problématiques qui était déjà
existantes avant mais les phénomènes de
crise non les ont amplifié puis les ont
surtout mis dans le débat public
et quand on dit ça c'est aussi
implicitement de ça revient
implicitement à dire également que quand
la crise du coït terminera pas ça
j'aimerais un jour mais on espère bien
sûr les problématiques de santé mentale
des étudiants perdureront probablement
si les réponses en termes de politiques
publiques notamment de ne sont pas
apportées donc nous sommes bien dans une
analyse à la fois de bien sûr de
comprendre ce qui se passe actuellement
mais de relativiser ça ou de rapporter à
des phénomènes qui existait avant et qui
peuvent perdurer bien sûr après la crise
3 3 grands champs de questions
qui correspondent aux questionnaires
cadiou vous est envoyé d'abord si vous
pouviez nous faire un point sur l'état
de santé psychologique des étudiants
quels sont les maux dont il souffre
quelles sont les causes de ces
souffrances
est-ce que de par vos expériences
respectives
vous voyez une évolution ces dernières
années où finalement ce dont on parle
actuellement était déjà dans les mêmes
proportions sur les mêmes
caractéristiques déjà présents sont des
sujets qui nous apporte pour bien
identifier
l'état de santé psychologique évidemment
au regard de cet état de santé quelques
l organisation des offres de soins et
mise en place ou devrait être mise en
place pour répondre plus spécifiquement
à la question et étudiantes réponse au
sein des établissements d'enseignement
supérieur universitaire et autres et
réponses aussi en liaison avec le reste
du réseau de santé je pense à la
médecine de ville ou à la médecine
hospitalière
évidemment dès lors qu'on parle des
problématiques de de soins de santé
psychologique se pose des questions plus
spécifiques d'identification de repérage
de signalements et d'identification on
voudrait savoir si là aussi les outils
existants ou les
les des organisations mises en place
sont satisfaisantes pour identifier les
éditions en souffrance ont pris bien sûr
la prise en charge qui peut suivre dès
lors que a besoin est clairement
identifiée par rapport à cette offre de
soins
on voudrait aussi vous entendre sur les
réponses qui ont été apportées plus
spécifiquement ces dernières semaines où
ces derniers mois par le gouvernement
par rapport à la situation liée aux
coville en particulier sur l' annonce
peut-être la plus dire c'est le coin qui
a été le plus entendu le chèque 7,6 g
pascal efficiency ou sexy que le voyez
c'est le choc ce type par an j'avais un
doute en le disant le sexy est-ce que de
poids votre point de vue c'est pertinent
est ce que ça doit être prolongé et puis
dernier chant de questions c'est les
politiques de prévention en matière de
santé psychologique
là aussi quel est votre point de vue sur
les dispositifs existants les actions
menées à la fois sur l'existant comme je
disais à l'instant mais aussi sur ce qui
pourrait être fait comme enseignement de
ce que nous vivons depuis quelques
semaines monsieur larsen avoue nom
propre pour environ 10 minutes prenez en
un peu de temps merci je vous remercie
pour votre invitation pour ce tour de
table que je l'espère riches parce que
la situation mérite qu'on s'y oppose et
surtout qu'on lisse et d'échanger sur
une problématique qui me semblent
chronique je rejoins monsieur le
sénateur sur l'idée qu' il ya un effet
filtre de cette crise parce que ces
problèmes inscrit à exister et peut-être
on les avait pas tous collectivement en
mesure et on n'avait pas mesuré l'impact
je vais faire juste une petite
présentation de l'université pour vous
donner un contexte de l'étude parce que
c'est assez important c'est une
université
ces universitaires 18 verne qui est sûr
c'est qu'on puces 32 mille étudiants qui
couvre l'ensemble des champs de
formation de la santé jusqu'à la
philosophie en couvrant les quatre
domaines et qui est assez je dirais
assez bien aux déployés dans le
territoire avec ses complices le la
sociologie de les étudiants c'est 54 %
des étudiants sont boursiers
un tiers sans salariés et un tiers des
étudiants sur le campus un minois sens
en mobilité c'est-à-dire n'auriez dans
pas sur amiens sur un lien il ya
vingt-six mille étudiants ça fait un
habitant sur cinq
ces jeux rapportent ça au co de
l'étudiant l'université représente
l'équivalent de 180 millions d'euros
d'activité au niveau d'amiens donc c'est
à dire que c'est vraiment le coeur
battant de la ville maintenant revenons
en à la problématique de l'aco vide
j'en tire deux conclusions si vous
permettez
la première des choses au delà de
l'étude qui a été évoqué par monsieur le
président tout à l'heure c'est une étude
qui a été menée par un étudiant de
médecine santé publique dans le cadre de
santé publique france donc vous
connaissez un petit peu le résultat ça
c'est le contexte mais je voulais juste
mesure et quelques points qui me semble
important
le premier point avant le 14 janvier
dans le discours politique comme le
discours économique il n'y avait pas le
mot étudiants et ça a été ressentie très
mal vous avez dit sûre pour deux raisons
la première si vous vous souvenez on a
instauré la digue de distance yale et la
problématique journalistique
ça a été de la triche c'est quand même
assez compliqué de déplacer le problème
sur autre chose que le bien-être et
l'appropriation du savoir via quelque
chose de nouveau qui s'appelle de
distance il la deuxième chose et elle
est bien sûr dans 34 ou l'avait vu les
plus impactés sans les el3 licence iii
et m1 ceux qui postulent vers un master
et ceux qui vont postuler demain vers un
emploi et pourquoi ces deux catégories
là parce que va justement la notion du
stage l'anus de la mission d'insertion
la notion aussi de réussir un deuxième
concours pour aller vers l'ouest a donc
cette absence là n'est pas anodine n'est
pas du tout neutre parce que
parallèlement on a autorisé les bts et
les prépas qui concourent au même
concours que de continuer en présentiel
alors pour moi c'est pas du tout neutre
et ça ressort parce que depuis l'étude
on a pris un certain nombre de mesures
et parmi ces mesures là on a fait des
groupes du groupe de parole et ça
ressort la déconsidération ressort
beaucoup dans dans le discours étudiants
pourquoi pourquoi ça ressort et ça
s'amplifie
je dis que ça existait avant la cette
pandémie
moi j'avais rappelé à la ministre
quand elle est venue le voir c'est que
l'allusion de soukouss il ya une sous
couche qu'on a vécu collectivement mais
on l'a ressenti individuellement parce
que tout le monde n'a pas les mains
fondement et c'est là où ça se joue
justement
la notion de ces considérations à côté
de ça il y a donc on a clivé les choses
et surtout surtout ce qu'est ce qui
s'est posée par la suite c'est qu'on a
pensé que se focaliser sur la précarité
étudiante sur la fracture numérique
suffisait en fait il fallait utiliser
comme des paramètres pour comprendre ce
qui se passe en s'est rendu compte dire
le distanti elle ne nous fait pas
oublier le fait qu'il existe des zones
blanches et des zones qu'ils n'ont pas
de nette dans nos régions
pas simplement en france et partout donc
là on a distribué nous ça nous a coûté
le premier confinement jeu qu'en
décembre c'est à peu près 1,1 million
d'euros 700 ordinateurs de distribuer
500 clés 4g
tous les étudiants salariés arrêtés ont
été payés soit dans le privé sont au
sein des universités donc on a fait cet
effort là mais c'est pas suffisant
ça c'est juste pour rappel ce à réparer
mais pour le moment par contre on n'a
pas donné une projection à mesure il ya
3 il ya trois je penserai un triptyque
dans cette crise le premier triptyque ça
a été les allemands pour rompre pendant
pour rompre la contagion ca c c'est
important rampera la contagion havrais
rompre l'isolément est ensuite projeté
donc on a vécu dans des scénarios
évolutifs sans projection
c'est pour ça comme on notera pour notre
université on l'avait affirmé clairement
pas ce que prétend diversité à cette
liberté là par rapport à un vecteur pour
avoir quelqu'un de nommer sait qu'il
peut être maître du lieu
nous avons fermé l'université avant le
discours du président vaincu et que nous
avons fermé au mois de février
parce qu'on a eu des premiers cas au
mois de février dans l'oise et on a
décidé qu'à partir du 1er février 2021
en stabilise
l'agenda parce que c'est normal nous
sommes dans une situation de crise qui
évolue c'est la recherche tels que ceux
pratiqués dans nos laboratoires et
flatte c'est pas une question de
certitude la recherche ouvre des
horizons
elle ne répond pas et c'est ça le
spectacle qu'on ait vues et les gens
peut-être en confrontation ses
recherches mais je vais pas je vais pas
m'étaler là-dessus il ya nuance entre
christophe colomb et magellan donc celui
qui trouve et c'est lui qui ouvre des
horizons
mais ça c'est physiciens qui parle donc
il ya vraiment une différence qu'il faut
nous c'est pour nous il fallait qu'on
projette nos étudiants et qu'on produise
du discours positif donc parmi les
choses qui ont été mises en place pour
répondre à cette crise c'est que d'abord
on a stabilisé la gendarme a ouvert des
ateliers culture avec les artistes des
résidences d'artistes évidemment
d'ankara dans la loire sommes des
républicains si donc on a ouvert des
ateliers aussi sportif on a ouvert des
concours artistiques entre composantes
centralisée on a essayé de faire du lien
autrement peut parler de lutte il en a
besoin d'un peu de parler inutile parce
que à force de parler utile en
permanence on en perd la substance la
deuxième chose on leur a dit quelle que
soit l'issue ça c'est important qu'elles
entendent quelle que soit l'issue de
cette crise se taira la rentrée il y
aura de toutes façons de la
consolidation disciplinaire au choix 2
pour les étudiants qui ne trouveront pas
déçu on préfère les inscrire chez nous
sur la notion de double compétence
plutôt couderc ou de les laisser dans
une situation d'échec et pour les
étudiants qui sont insérés et partiront
avec ce que j'appelle mon estime de soi
quand même un peu écornée on leur offre
20% de leur temps en accord avec
l'entreprise pour de la consolidation
c'est à dire on leur a donné un discours
positif d'accompagnement à la rentrée
déjà pour ce soit important évidemment
on a divisé les syndicats patronaux on a
discuté avec le territoire avec les
politiques pour qu'on puisse donner un
discours positif mais on sait
pertinemment qu'il sera pas suffisant
nous avons conscience que ce sont des
mesures pour positiver
derrière se nichent quelque chose qui me
semblent importantes a souligné la crise
organique de l'université de manière
générale tout à l'heure je faisais des
chiffres sur amiens
l'université n'est pas perçue
aujourd'hui dans la cartographie
française comme un moteur économique
quand on a parlé de pas de plan de
relance on n'a pas parlé d'université
alors c'est un investissement
la deuxième chose qui me semblent
importantes concernant l'université
toujours c'est que au dollar de fait
quel relais et qu'elle crée les lions
nous ont bien fait comprendre qu'ils ne
viennent pas que pour les diplômes ils
viennent aussi pour autre chose pour se
structurer pour faire des choix pour un
petit peu rompre avec leur famille sur
la poule promet confinement je vous la
vouge avait peut-être un préjugé de
profs de base c'est que je pensais que
dans les campus
au niveau des villes j'allais trouver
que les idées internationaux
c'était qu'au 40% 60% c'était des
étudiants qui étaient dans des zones
blanches en rupture familiale
voilà qui sont retrouvés dans cette
situation et qu'il fallait absolument
répondre
après tout alors je vais parler des le
sens de cette de 7,2 de cette crise ce
qui se cache derrière c'est lorsque
l'université on a fait de la
massification on y adhère
on adhère à la notion de massification
mais la question c'est que l'évolution
de l'effectif n'a jamais été accompagnée
par une évolution de moyens en moyenne
je vais fait rien en moyens parce que je
veux parler au nom s'aimer mais mes
colères les autres universitaires
l'évolution était de 20 % annuellement
avec une évolution de moyenne de 13%
vous regardez un effet cumulé sur dix
ans vous allez voir un petit peu la
catastrophe en terme d'organisation
c'est à dire lorsque en annonces
l'accueil d'étudiants en annonce en
permanence la dégradation des conditions
de travail parce qu'on dit on a augmenté
chaque année en france on peut vraiment
universités voilà mon genou droit si on
dit que nous avons tant d'étudiants et
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour la nation
parce qu'on forme davantage de temps
donc si on est en train d'aller vers une
cité du savoir
vous savez en dégradent nos conditions
de travail et on se retrouve dans mon
humble situation mais c'est la situation
de tous les présidents à choisir entre
une mission d'enseignement et de
recherche
est-ce qu'on choisit un prof on choisit
un médecin vous voyez donc là il ya
quelque chose que la crise nous a révélé
c'est que derrière se cache le manque de
moyens derrière ce que pense une prise
de conscience
l'état de nos étudiants quand les
étudiants et on vous le dit on le dit
tout ce que le par exemple le niveau a
baissé
ils en ont conscience ils savent qu'ils
viennent n'ont pas une très haute estime
d'eux quand ils sentent à l'université
notre rôle c'était de ne rien chanter et
de laisser de les pousser vers la
réussite
oui si en plus vous les ouvriers dans le
discours vous ne parlez pas à eux et que
ça soit ils sont considérés comme du
type digestive devant un écran
évidemment il ya un effet crise a fait
que ces choses-là se sont vraiment un
petit peu exposé un dos en aux yeux je
vais à l'heure de ce président a parlé
de 19% dans les 19 % il ya soixante-six
pour cent quand scénarisé leur suicide
c'est à dire ils ont parlé de cordes de
gaz de se jeter sur les rails
c'est pas notre canton scénarise quand
on en a on a des pensées suicidaires
mais je pense que nous avons des
spécialistes qui peut démêler ce type de
problématique quand on est à la
scénarisation ça c'est problématique
parce que nous on le prend comme un
échec
en tant qu'éducateur on se dit quelque
chose qu'on n'a pas vu qu'on avait
aperçu et je voulais pas vous replomber
avec mon témoignage mais je voulais
juste dire que ce qui nous manque nous
d'avoir au delà je vais pas faire la
pleureuse il nous faut des moyens il
faut une prise de conscience collective
ce que nous voulons faire dans nos
étudiants ne sera pas les universités de
répondre si une réponse sociétale qu'il
faut la deuxième chose qui me semblent
importantes et qu'il faut peut-être on
adresse à nos jeunes parce qu'on leur
parle pas assez
on est en train de leur dire grosso modo
c'est la guerre j'ai noté ce moment-là
l'âge de l'histoire fait date quand on
déclare la guerre en déclarant la guerre
ça veut dire qu'on met les jeunes au
front et on dit le court qu'il en coûte
c'est là au menton peu présent je pose
de problème ça veut dire quoi quoi qu'il
en coûte
il s'agit de qui et combien et comment
parce que c est faux là c'est là où la
politique commence dans le sens noble
calme
donc ils entendent ça ils attendent
aussi la dette donc vous allez faire les
gars vous allez le payer et en plus
c'est à la dette et je crois que dans le
discours politique il faudrait contrôler
les formules juste nous savons très bien
que la situation est compliquée pour
tout le monde
je ne serai là je ne serais pas là en
train de vous dire il l'aurait fallu
je ne suis pas médecin je ne suis pas
psychologue je suis physicien
modestement je peux parler de physique
mais le reste est des gens ça va en
parler mieux que moi les scientifiques
comme ça que chacun quand je les
scientifiques dans le sens large et un
chacun parle derrière sa posture
disciplinaire parle de ce qu'il sait et
c'est de le dire au mieux
plutôt que de dire ce qu'on a vu à mon
avis avoir un avis qu'une chose se
forger un avis en est une autre
il ya une nuance entre la vie et le
jugement et c'est pour ça que je vais
pas qu'on fait ça le dernier point que
je l'évoqué parce que je sais que je
suis dans les dix minutes
c'est la notion de là près parce que
j'ai on a beaucoup entendu cette notion
là les historiens parlent mieux que nous
l'apprennent le savent les trois choses
qui vont sortir dans la presse
trois choses l'amnésie la problématique
de saint-augustin c'est à dire vouloir
rattraper le temps et la cristallisation
des certitudes les entiére et les
eurosceptiques se rend aux sceptiques le
pro européens seront prêts européens
faut rien espérer de la presse si on
n'investit pas maintenant si on se dit
pas quelque chose qu'il faut faire pour
7 après les mois je pense que pour
l'après on aura un petit peu d'excès une
fougue qu'il faudrait peut-être encadré
il faut une offre plus importante
on va peut-être patrick parlera de
nombre de psy en écosse moi j'étais
choqué en écosse il ya quand même cinq
fois moins d'étudiants que au niveau de
francs français
ils ont débloqué 80 postes de
psychologues pour l'échec
en picardie c'est le sud de france et
que si psychologues sont proposés pour
prendre les chèques pour moi ça c'est
pas une réussite
certainement pas une réussite et ça se
comprend
on a du mal nous à les attirer vers nous
parce que nous sommes bloqués par la
tarification elles sont bloquées par un
certain nombre de problématiques et puis
ils ont beaucoup à faire avec cette
crise donc on va pas les surcharger mais
je crois que juste pour conclure pour la
presse il va falloir repenser notre
modèle va falloir repenser ce que nous
allons dire aux étudiants de septembre
parce qu'on va se retrouver des études
ont qu une des élèves qui n'ont pas vu
de preuves pendant quasiment deux ans et
dl3 parce que je laisse aux causes nous
sommes à la deuxième je pense qu'il y en
aura un troisième à la rentrée je pense
qu'on aura une quatrième ou cinquième
dans deux ans trois ans parce que ça va
c'est un effet retard qui se joue je
veux conclure là dessus c'est qu'elle
soyons vigilants sur cette après là
parce que il faut construire maintenant
c'est maintenant que pour faire des
propositions pour 7 après faut rien
espérer d'une crise à part qu'elles
n'atteignent pas les nôtres voilà merci
monsieur le président merci pour la très
grande qualité de votre intervention
très haute avec des perspectives tout à
fait tout à fait intéressante et que on
espère collectivement lumineuse pour
sortir du tunnel dans lequel nous sommes
nous sommes tous sans transition ce que
ça serait difficile d'en faire une
je vais j'ai passé la parole au docteur
alger au docteur bigot vous organisez
votre temps de parole comme comme vous
le souhaitez vous avez environ 10
minutes
oui s'il vous plaît mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs merci beaucoup de nous
recevoir nous sommes venus sur place on
avait le choix sur place et en
présentiel
on a bien sûr fait le choix de de la
présence je dis ça par rapport à ce qui
s'est passé avec les étudiants pendant
la campagne unitaire mais nous comme les
étudiants on préfère ça aussi oui il
s'est battu comme tout le monde on
préparait tous mes et je voulais
témoigner de ce qui s'est passé c'est à
dire pendant le premier confinement les
étudiants n'ont pas pu venir et on a
maintenu nos séances pendant les trois
mois en distance yale et le deuxième
confinement il avait le choix
99% sont venus sur place et donc ça ça
nous paraît important que quand à la
dimension de l'incarnation dans le soin
elle est essentielle donc ça c'est voilà
c'était un propos par lequel je voulais
commencer parce que ça me paraît très
important par rapport à ce qu'il peut se
discuter aussi sur ce qu'on peut faire
pour les étudiants je crois que cette
dimension là elle est très importante
donc au départ il m'a été demandé de
faire une présentation sur l'action
concrète du battu pascal est l'état des
lieux des difficultés psychologiques et
puis j'ai pensé qu' il serait
intéressant de faire cette présentation
de manière conjointe avec terrible igo
qu'on vous a présenté qui est donc
responsable d'une unité
d'hospitalisation dédié aux étudiants
dans le service de psychiatrie de
l'hôtel dieu à l'ap-hp est-il si on a
pensé que ce serait intéressant de venir
ensemble c'est parce que d'une part
comme moi c'est un acteur de terrain et
vous parlera de sa clinique et d'autre
part parce que nous travaillons ensemble
au quotidien depuis des années dans le
cadre d'un réseau de soins franciliens
qui s'appelle respect et dont il vous
parlera aussi il nous paraît essentiel
que vous connaissiez l'existence de ce
réseau
alors j'en viens au bas depuis les
bureaux d'aidé psychologique
universitaire donc et je vais vous
parler du bas puis pascal mais je me
fais en même temps le porte parole d'une
association tout jeunes nés en 2010
et qui fédère les 18 bapu qui existent
en france 18 bapu c'est très peu elle
regroupe donc cette association tous les
professionnels engagés dans le travail
dans les barbus qui vous partagent leurs
expériences cliniques et leurs
expériences institutionnels rapport avec
les tutelles donc on échange aussi
beaucoup sur ces thèmes là et ce qui est
très frappant c'est que on vient de 18
endroits différents
1 ce qui est très frappant c'est que au
delà d'une certaine diversité des
pratiques est liée à l'histoire locale
des institutions et une convergence des
cliniciens sur des fondamentaux de la
prise en charge des étudiants en
souffrance dont j'ai essayé de témoigner
en partant du bas pu donc le but pascal
historiquement c'est le premier il a été
créé en 1956 et il a été créé par une
mutuelle étudiante la mnef elle même
issue d'un syndicat étudiant l'unef
à l'issue des travaux d'un comité
national universitaire pour la santé
mentale dans lequel les vues de
multiples intervenants
alors ce qu'il faut souligner au passage
et monsieur le président l'a rappelé
tout à l'heure c'est que depuis les
années 70
l'eba pu mais aussi les services de
santé universitaire avec qui nous
travaillons en étroite collaboration
n'ont obtenu presque aucun moyen
supplémentaire alors que la population
étudiante a été multiplié par huit dans
ces 50 dernières années dans certaines
grandes villes universitaires comme
nantes bordeaux toulouse et lyon il n'y
a pas de bavure alors le texte qui
définit l'agrément débat puce s'appelle
l' annexe 33 indique qu'il s'agit de
proposer une aide psychologique gratuite
afin de prévenir dépister et traiter les
étudiants qui souffre de troubles
mentaux de difficultés psychologiques
c'est dans le texte et c'est ce qu'on
fait elle gratuite c'est essentiel le
coût des soins est reconnu comme un
obstacle majeur pour que les étudiants
se soigne ils n'ont pas les moyens de se
payer une aide psychologique puisque
ligne gagne pas encore leur vie
ou s'il la gagne c'est pour payer leurs
études et très souvent ils ne veulent
pas s'adresser à leurs parents pour une
berline démarche qui s'inscrit dans un
processus d'autonomisation donc la
gratuité c'est essentiel prévenir
dépister et traiter ça aussi c'est très
important
l'eba pu depuis qu'ils existent assure
c'est trois fonctions leurs combinaisons
dans un même lieu est un formidable
atout la prévention et le dépistage ne
sont pas là parce que l'apanage des bas
puis à d'autres structures qui y
participent
mais ce sont les seules structures
publiques destinées aux étudiants qui
permettent un traitement
ce qu'on appelle des structures d'aval
le bac pascal accueille tous les
étudiants de milieux d'âge de pays
différents d'autant qu'il a une antenne
à la cité internationale de l'université
de paris il est rattaché à la clinique
médicaux universitaires georges hier
il fait partie de la fondation santé des
étudiants de france c'est un avantage
fort pour insérer les prises en charge
dans un parcours de soins
l'arrivée récente d'un chef de clinique
dans le dispositif s'inscrit dans une
volonté de la fondation de développer un
pôle ambulatoire hospitalo
universitaires destiné aux étudiants
le papy pascal est ouvert aux étudiants
quels que soient leur demander leur
psychopathologie toutefois tous peuvent
s'y rendre
quel que soit l'établissement dans
lequel ils sont inscrits publics ou
privés écoles bts tout mais aussi quels
que soient leur domicile ou leur lieu de
scolarisation
la majorité des étudiants viennent touba
pu de leur propre initiative
ça c'est très important c'est à dire ils
sont pas on en a beaucoup qui poussent
la porte ils nous trouvent sur internet
où ils ont le bouchât havrais mais c'est
un aspect essentiel
la majorité de ceux qui viennent se
débrouille pour arriver jusqu'à nous
outre la gratuité
le fait qu'il soit en dehors de leur
lieu d'étude facilite la démarche car il
est sur la confidentialité et protège
d'une stigmatisation réel ou redouté
parfois quelques rencontres suffisent
pour une étude dénouer une situation
la durée de la prise en charge la
fréquence des rencontres sont ajustés à
chacun en moyenne la durée d'un an
mais ça recouvre des réalités très
différentes
rent les étudiants que nous voyons
souffrent principalement de stress de
troubles du sommeil d'anxiété de des
principes dépression mais aussi
d'isolement et de blocage dans leurs
études évidemment que avec la crise
sanitaire
la problématique de l' isolement et du
décrochage est devenu majeur
catastrophique
certains ont des idées suicidaires ça a
été évoqué et puis différents troubles
des conduites ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que ces symptômes s'inscrivent
toujours dans une histoire
il révèle une fragilité qui est mis à
jour par ce moment charnière en
particulier du point de vue d'autonomie
qu'est le temps des études et c'est pour
ça aussi qu'on a beaucoup d'étudiants
qui décompensent en ce moment c'est à
dire que ceux qui n'auraient pas des
compensées sans la crise sont exposées à
un stress plus fort et dès qu'on pense
et donc c'est très important de règles
de les accueillir dans ce temps-là on
pour que la souffrance que montrent
leurs symptômes n'évolue pas vers un
trouble et non seulement ça mais aussi
puis pour que on les lisent arrive à
faire des choix de vie qui leur
permettent de se trouver et qu'il aurait
vite de devenir des adultes malheureux
et qui coûte très cher à la société
alors il ya que 2 va plus à paris le
papy pascal et le bape luxembourg qui
est géré par la croix rouge
ils assurent à eux deux 17 mille actes
et accueille mille étudiants par an et
cela avec 13,5 équivalents temps pleins
de cliniciens je vous dis pas le budget
c'est dérisoire mais il y a quatre cent
mille étudiants dans les universités
parisiennes 600000 en ile de france
parce que les bateaux parisiens
reçoivent aussi bien des étudiants de
paris que des étudiants qui viennent qui
sont demeure en banlieue les battues
sont saturées depuis des années depuis
des années on le crie nous sommes
constamment confrontés à des questions
éthiques pour gérer les listes
d'attentes constamment et qui s'est dit
ou non de
la crise sanitaire sur les services de
réanimation qui sait cette apparu comme
insupportable c'est quelque chose à quoi
on est confrontés nous depuis des années
c'est à dire qu'est ce qu'on fait il va
mal oui mais il ya l'autre qui attend
depuis longtemps que c'est on est amené
à faire un pas ramener dans des
discussions éthique très compliquée et
qui qui nous rendent moins disponibles
pour notre travail
voilà je passe la parole à attirer bigot
merci encore mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs d'auditionner des cliniciens
de terrain je vous parlais pas mal de
cliniques d'ailleurs impliqué dans la
prise en charge et la souffrance au
quotidien des des étudiants comme l'a
dit frédéric 4g c'est à ce titre en tant
que praticien hospitalier responsable de
cette unité à l'hôtel-dieu dédié aux
étudiants mais aussi au titre de
vice-président du réseau respect que je
m'adresse à vous respect respect comme
réseaux de soins psychiatriques et
psychologiques pour les étudiants
partant du constat que les différentes
structures de soins psy et étudiants
fonctionné trop souvent de manière clivé
les unes des autres et que de ce fait
l'offre de soins apparaissait éclaté
sans la cohérence requises pour la prise
en charge des difficultés psychologiques
le réseau associatif respect s'est
constitué en 2008 et a eu comme objectif
d'inclure tous les acteurs de la prise
en charge des troubles psychiques
proposé aux étudiants de paris et d'île
de france
alors c'est s'est ouvert à tous mais
principalement médecin généraliste en a
pas beaucoup pas suffisamment d'ailleurs
spécialistes libéraux de la même façon
ça fait partie des objectifs de
l'association que de développer en
raison de ce qu'ils évoquaient frédéric
un instant c'est à dire la question de
la les spécialistes libéraux c'est la
question de la dea du du paiement aussi
d'aider des soins et donc c'est pas
évident de trouver un réseau d'aval
mais ça regroupe aussi tous les services
de médecine préventive universitaire
interuniversitaire des structures de
consultations spécialisées
donc bien sûr les bacs eu des cmpp donc
le centre médico psycho psychologie que
vous sicaud pédagogiques ou d'autres
consultations spécialisées
ça peut être le notamment au dos tout
début venait pas mal le cepeo à quai le
centre psychiatrique d'orientation et
d'accueil à sainte anne qui a ouvert une
accueil pour les jeunes adultes ça
regroupait aussi ça regroupe toujours
des établissements d'hospitalisation
psychiatrique qui reçoivent des
étudiants des structures associatives
privé la fondation de santé étudiants de
france etc
à l'époque l'idée était de mettre en
place un réseau de soins ouvert qui
permettait de faire le lien entre les
structures par une meilleure
connaissance mutuelle des fonctionnement
de chacune d'entre elles est de
favoriser une meilleure articulation des
soins psychiques apporter aux étudiants
que ce soit par l'intermédiaire de
raccourcissement des délais de délais de
prise en charge une meilleure
coordination
la mise en place de projets
thérapeutiques élaboré au cas par cas
par différentes les différentes
structures impliquées
il s'agit aussi bien sur ce réseau d'un
lieu d'échangé de partage de formation
pour les psychologues psychiatres
généraliste et assistants sociaux qui
participent au réseau
aujourd'hui c'est le seul réseau
fonctionnel de ce type dédié
spécifiquement à la santé psychique des
étudiants il est ouvert à tous les
acteurs de la prise en charge
psychiatrique et psychologique des
étudiants
outre la poursuite des objectifs initié
son nom l'ambition de respect est
plurielle elle est de mobiliser d'autres
structures de soin jusqu'ici peu ou
encore non impliqués dans le réseau y en
a plus en plus maintenant sur paris donc
l'idée ce serait même potentiellement
d'aller un peu plus vers le national de
d'impliquer de 2
d'autres acteurs permettant à orléans
libéral tenant compte de la
problématique financière des étudiants
ce que j'évoquais à l'instant pour
assurer une continuité de prise en
charge notamment favoriser le
développement de projets et de
dispositifs innovants sensibilisés aux
problématiques spécifiques des étudiants
autant le grand public que les acteurs
du champ sanitaire on se rend compte
combien le grand public a découvert lors
de cette crise
combien les étudiants pouvaient souffrir
mais on le sait depuis longtemps très
longtemps
1 je reviendrai tout à l'heure il ya
plein de rapports qui ont déjà évoqué sa
de très longue date mais là la mise en
scène médiatique je dirais liés au co
vide a bien sûr ac utiliser tout ça est
fait prendre conscience
l'idée de l'it aussi de pour le réseau
de promouvoir une prévention primaire
secondaire et tertiaire efficiente et
spécialisés pour les étudiants et bien
sûr de se structurer potentiellement on
a longuement hésité en véritable réseau
de soins avec des moyens pérennes
la difficulté c'est quand on se
structure vraiment vu en vrai réseau de
soins les moyens sont jamais pérenne
donc il faut relancer des dossiers et on
est tous des cliniciens des cliniciens
qui passe énorme et enfin moi je suis à
80 10 % de mon activité c'est de la
clinique et on est tous débordés ce qui
fait que c'est pas évident de relancer
des dossiers et c'est là mon implication
dans ce réseau se situe en amont de sa
création d'ailleurs parce que j'étais à
auparavant à cocher
j'étais responsable d'unité de
l'hospitalisation d'un service de
psychiatrie et on avait à l'époque bien
longtemps avant la création de respect
on avait déjà passé une convention avec
le bas du luxembourg dans pour améliorer
justement les liens et que le peuple
luxembourg puis hospitalisé plus
facilement chez nous et de la même façon
qu'on puisse avoir plus de 2
de contacts et de faciliter éventuel
pour des patients qui était urgente dans
une prison pour une prise en charge
psychothérapeutique
cette implication de ma part est
directement liée à ma pratique clinique
auprès des étudiants reçus en
consultation hospitalisé à l'hôtel-dieu
c'est à l'hôtel dieu c'est une unité
ouverte qui accueille des patients en
service libre donc qui viennent qui sont
volontaires pour leurs soins on y reçoit
des patients adressés par des
correspondants par les membres du réseau
ou encore ou encore via les urgences et
on en a eu beaucoup via les urgences est
de plus en plus bien urgence
il s'agit pour la plupart des étudiants
en situation de décompensation psychique
au sens du passage d'un état stable à
une rupture d'équilibré le sens
systémique de delà de la crise un
finalement avec apparition de symptômes
psychopathologique dont certains ont
déjà été évoquées par frédéric à jay et
notamment d étancher aiguë des troubles
dépressifs de plus en plus majeur des
troubles des conduites alimentaires des
troubles addictifs des désorganisations
d'azur psychotique et bien sûr des
idéations suicidaires ou des mises en
actes auto hétéro agressif c'est à dire
des passages à l'acte suicidaire
potentiellement ou hétéro agressifs les
raisons des décès des compensations sont
multiples et ne sont spécifiques et à
ses nombreuses que ce soient les enjeux
académique conjuguée avec une
vulnérabilité psychique personnel propre
à cet âge de la vie où se joue
l'autonomisation la socialisation et la
construction d'une d'une des parties de
notre identité qui est la partie
professionnelle 1
les renoncements nécessaire au choix
d'orientation conjuguée aux pressions
académique ou familiales et ou familiale
beaucoup de nos étudiants arrivent en
hospitalisation son pont se sont
pressurisées que ce soit d'ailleurs par
l'académie parler les enjeux académique
et par ou par la famille leur propre
famille qui peut parfois mettre une
pression sans compter qu'ils ont eux
mêmes cela colle directement ensuite un
environnement d'études - contenant au
départ puisque - contenant est souvent
plus anonymes que dans le secondaire d
une éventuelle séparation du foyer
familial soit en raison du lieu d'études
soit par désir d'autonomisation la
paupérisation des étudiants qui est de
plus en plus importante
un plus d'un tiers aujourd'hui sont en
très grandes difficultés financières
les la massification de l'enseignement
supérieur une sélectivité accrue des
idéaux de résultats parfois malmenée par
la réalité de ceux ci et on voit ça
notamment dans les grandes écoles ou
dans les grandes écoles
il ya une pression jeudi c'est presque
un honneur que d'avoir à 1,5 à 5 sur 20
et sur le plan de l'estimé de soi ça
peut créer pour un certain nombre
beaucoup de dégâts sans compter la
pression des professeurs mais ça peut
être aussi à la fac de la même façon et
bien sûr toutes les difficultés
d'insertion futur dans le milieu
professionnel qui sont encore plus
aggravé ses angoisses de lier à la aux
futurs professionnels sont majorés
actuellement les effets de la pandémie
justement l'isolément social le
sentiment d'enfermement l'impossibilité
de se projeter les incertitudes sur cet
avenir la précarité encore accru on a
tout le monde a en tête bien sûr les
étudiants faisant la queue pour avoir
des plateaux repas ou des choses
gratuites quoi hein
le télé-enseignement langois ce regard
des effets du virus qu'il faut pas
négliger
beaucoup de jeunes ont finalement une
très grande inquiétude au regard du
virus tout ça est excellent on tous ces
éléments ont exacerbé cette réalité
parfois précipité des étudiants dans des
troubles psychiques dans ces troubles
psychiques et pour certains
malheureusement vers le suicide et on en
a eu un certain nombre et des tentatives
ça on en a aujourd'hui
actuellement plus de 60 % des lits
totaux du service donc on a une unité
qui au total fait 27 lits oui c'est ça
même si tu lis plus de 60% des lithos du
service sont occupés par des étudiants
ça va au delà de l'unité que je dont
j'ai la responsabilité
une grande majorité d'entre eux sont
hospitalisés pour des idées à sion ou
des tentatives de suicide
ce qui est quand même très très marquant
il y en a toujours eu mais le taux est
de plus en plus important à ce propos
d'ailleurs on a mis en place dans le
service une cellule téléphonique de
régulation de l'offre de soin en sus
idéologie qui peut permettre des
professionnels de santé tous types de
professionnels de santé et notamment à
penser beaucoup pour les pour les
étudiants mais aussi pour les la police
d'ailleurs
[Musique]
qui leur permettent d'aider à
l'évaluation et l'orientation des
patients ceux ci d'air ou sucide ans
selon la disponibilité des structures
ambulatoires et hospitalière pour bon
nombre d étudiants
c'est une première hospitalisation en
psychiatrie voir un premier contact
outre la prise en charge classique des
troubles psychiatriques le travail avec
les étudiants présentent des
spécificités tant sur le plan
relationnel que dans la prise en compte
de la temporalité des études au regard
de la temporalité psychique c'est à dire
les études elle continue la temporalité
des études elle et elle est linéaire la
temporalité psychique c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué ce qui fait que beaucoup
d'étudiants sont un certain moment pris
en difficulté parce que sur le plan
psychique c'est difficile d'avancer et
en même temps la temporalité des études
elle élève ans 7 7
sur le plan relationnel la demande de
ces jeunes et souvent peu claires au
départ et multiples que concerne la
souffrance internes donnent une réalité
interne mais aussi une souffrance liée à
des facteurs externes divers elle
s'exprime souvent sur un mode où il est
difficile de la verbaliser directement
ils sont encore en sortie d'adolescence
pour un certain nombre donc la
verbalisation et biella la l'arrivée l
élaboration des choses est compliqué on
entend quand même beaucoup de je sais
pas quand on leur pose une question
qu'est ce qu'est ce qui se passe je sais
pas et 7,7
ce qui fait que la la ce est la manière
dont ça s'exprime
ça va être souvent soit sur le mode
parfois de l'agressivité de la méfiance
pour la psychiatrie notamment pour des
premières premier contact ou sur celui
d'une attente massive avec une exigence
de soutien inconditionnel et permanent
sur presque sur un modèle parental
protecteur quoi est ce qui la plus
grande difficulté c'est d'arriver à
trouver cette bonne une bonne distance
relationnel pour rassurer et contenir
les angoisses d'un étudiant souvent très
perdu
c'est toute la difficulté aussi lors des
premiers entretiens des premiers
entretiens me contacter ou ce premier
contact avec un intervenant psy est un
contact très important parce que dans ce
premier contact va se jouer la confiance
la croche relationnel et la possibilité
de ne pas différer un des soins par la
suite et c'est r&d et finalement de
développer des troubles plus importants
toute la difficulté avec l'échec psy
l'évoquera peut-être lors des questions
tout à l'heure ce que j'ai pas
directement évoqué là mais c'est toute
la difficulté avec l'échec le psy
puisqu'il ya trois ans
procès ans renouvelable 3 quand une
accroche relationnel commencent à
apparaître
c'est difficile de fermer la porte un
étudiant qui donc il va investir déjà un
début de prise en charge de manière très
importante donc 7,7 pour nous c'est
d'arriver à trouver cette bonne distance
relationnel par ailleurs c'est ce que je
vous disais prendre en compte la
question des études qui envahit souvent
le discours des sujets qui sert souvent
d'ailleurs un peu d'écrans pour masquer
le mal est tout et tout est reporté
1 / sur les études et 7,7 et en même
temps il faut arriver à prendre en
compte cette question mais en permettant
aux étudiants de se dégager de la
culpabilité qui est associée sans perdre
de vue bien sûr la possible
participation des étudiants durant leur
hospitalisation ou de douze étapes clés
de l'étude des études
c'est à dire les limites de date pour
les choix de filière pour des rendus
important pour certains examens si
l'étudiant sens capable
dans certains cas c'est un travail de
deuil d'une filière d'études et la
construction d'une autre il faut qu'il
va falloir attendre accompagner tant sur
le plan psychologique que social durant
ce temps hospitalier la poursuite d'une
éventuelle psychothérapie et souvent
favorisé aussi je terminerai en
soulignant une nouvelle fois
l'importance du travail en réseau non
pas un réseau qui se décrète on peut
toujours pour mme état fort et on peut
toujours sauter sur sa chaise sur sa
chaise en criant comme un cabri en en
criant réseau réseau réseau c'est pas
comme ça qui se construit il se
construit lentement très progressivement
à part une connaissance de tous les
acteurs de terrain et c'est ici c'est un
processus qui prend du temps c'est
viennent nous ça fait des années
maintenant qu'on se connaît et on
travaille en toute confiance et c'est
pour les étudiants c'est fondamental
lorsqu'un étudiant décompensent vous
présenter un risque majeur il est
important d'agir rapidement mais sans
preuve sans précipitation ouais voilà
bah écoutez on va on va s'arrêter là
simplement pour conclure on avait on a
publié on a fait publier une tribune que
dont vous avez je pense à sa perte
d'éléments dans le dans le dossier est
bon dans cette tribune de cette
importance du travail de réseau en l'art
souligne mais on souligne surtout
l'importance de il ya des structures qui
existent
il ya plein de il ya des intervenants
certes la lisibilité et pas toujours
très claires parce que il y en a un
certain nombre et je pense que c'est
d'ailleurs ce serait l ars de pouvoir un
jour recensé ce serait 100 euros son
rôle recenser toutes les structures de
soins
sinon tout le monde se passe la main et
puis on dit toujours passé pléthorique
il ya beaucoup de structures de soins
etc
mais c'est passé par c'est pas forcément
le cas donc c'est vraiment un élément
fondamental mais les moyens actuels pour
nos structures les structures existantes
restent très insuffisants désolé d'avoir
dépassé je pensais qu'on avait un tout
petit peu plus merci beaucoup docteur
bigot parce que grâce à vous on a accédé
à un domaine dans lequel on ne rentre
jamais c'est celui de votre intervention
clinique et qui est pour un pour un
parlementaire quelque chose qui est
absolument inaccessible et donc on a pu
mesurer de façon très concrète qu'elle
pouvait être votre activité par rapport
à un public dont on a compris que
psychologiquement il était difficile
aussi à un cerner
avec votre autorisation je vais je vais
céder la parole à mesdames laurentine
veron et fanny sauvade pour passer à des
voir féminine après les voix masculines
et pas vous leurrez vous relégués en fin
d'intervention
donc je vous laisse la parole vous avez
dix minutes mais là j'ai du mal à vous
astreindre à un agenda bien bien contre
un avec les débordements qui ont eu lieu
avant donc si vous pouviez synthétique
ça serait très bien ça permettrait une
discussion après mes lames ce tabou oui
juste vous avez envoyé un powerpoint je
sais pas avec qui mais ce qui plaît
depuis un humain diffusé on peut essayer
c'est beau c'est commencer puis on va
essayer de voir comment peut on peut
faire c'est ça faire passer c'est
désormais pour notre invitation et de
nous donner l'opportunité nous exprimer
également en tant que co clinicienne
voilà faire notre maximum pour tenir le
timing et nous concentrer le coup sûr la
demande qui nous a été adressée initial
manqué de présenter notre travail de
terrain ou auprès des étudiants qui
pourront approfondir par la suite sur
d'autres questions
après les présentations de chacun donc
nous sommes un psychologue de formation
et nous avons créé il ya dix ans 11 ans
maintenant une association à but non
lucratif et donc à 6tu des cas pour
objectif de favoriser le bien-être des
étudiants ok puis ce n'est pas noël à
l'âge au niveau personnel et dans
l'heure actuelle puisque les deux
dimensions sont bien sûr impliqués nous
avons créé l'association à la sortie de
notre diplomation en psychologie faisant
en ça durant vos études qu'il y avait un
mal être étudiant prégnant et ce constat
elle était vérifiée via les enquêtes
étudiante sur la santé mentale qui à
l'époque déjà faisait état en fait d'une
prévalence de certaines difficultés
psychologiques de certains troubles ont
été déjà cité
l'anxiété la dépression d état de crise
suicidaire les addictions etc
donc nous avons créé l'association aussi
essentiellement en complémentarité des
services déjà existants à savoir laisser
là des services de santé universitaire
les battues mais voilà ces offres
d'accompagnement psychologique pouvait
en tout cas être limitée sur certains
territoires dont l'âge est
géographiquement donc nous sommes ça
nous allions derrière derrière nos
écrans et l'association a été créée à
lyon effectivement à à l'époque et c'est
toujours le cas
typiquement voilà il n'y a pas de bus à
lyon heureusement nous pouvons compter
voilà sur les centres de santé
universitaire mais l'idée c'était
vraiment de pouvoir aussi apporter une
réponse à ceux qui n'avaient pas accès à
ces services c'est à dire 40 % des
étudiants l'idée étant aussi pas de
vraiment avoir toute une dynamique qui
allait de la prévention à la promotion
de la santé mentale en passant par la
prise en charge puisqu'il ya des
troubles et c'est important de les
prendre en charge mais c'est aussi
important d'agir au plus tôt au plus
près des étudiants même quand il n'y a
pas de difficulté installés ou crds donc
l'idée aussi était d'avoir une structure
qui soit vraiment des stigmatisante et
avec des conditions d'accès facilité
pour lever les freins à la consultation
ce que vous inviter à avancer d'une ou
deux diapos c'est nous qui vous font
rire je ne sais pas un nom alors on ne
sait pas comment faire circuler le
dieppois non mais vous vous êtes au
sénat la pointe de la technologie toi
bien se passer mais encore en ruine si
c'est possible mais ce mois là merci
c'était juste voilà au revoir un support
visuel pour ce qui fonctionne lui de
cette manière là quelques chiffres clés
pour vous montrer un peu à quoi
ressemble aujourd'hui l'association donc
à situer c'est une présence dans plus de
40 villes de france mais une ouverture à
tous les étudiants de france qui sont
éligibles à nos actions nous
grâce à des interventions en distance
yale et plus récemment grâce à un
soutien de la fondation de france
voilà nos actions sont en fait
exclusivement par des psychologues
cliniciens qui interviennent sur le
terrain et elles sont financées par des
partenaires qu'il offre rempel voilà un
accompagnement psychologique et des
actions de prévention pour leurs
étudiants ces partenaires sont
essentiellement des établissements
d'enseignement supérieur et des
résidences universitaires que ce soit
les crous ou des résidences prix par
rapport à quelques chiffres d'évolution
puisqu'on parle de la crise par rapport
à l'année dernière qui était donc une
année coville est là on va vous donner
des chiffres qui sont partielle puisque
l'année est loin d'être finie nous on
avait effectivement mais une explosion
des demandes de rendez-vous +20 7% par
rapport à l'année dernière au niveau des
crises suicidaires c'est à dire que nous
on filtre les crises suicidaires au
niveau du secrétariat pouvoir les
évaluer les orienter en fonction de
l'urgence au plus 60 % par rapport à
l'année dernière c'était à dire que là
on en est déjà à 120 pour cette année et
là je ne parle pas de toutes les
situations qu'on est en consultation ce
qui est important de souligner aussi
c'est la mobilisation des acteurs autour
des étudiants et notamment des
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
on a eu énormément de sollicitations
alors déjà tous nos partenariats se sont
étoffées et tendu entre la dernière et
cette année pour répondre aux besoins
étudiants l'aller 142% en plus ce sont
des demandes de nouveaux partenariats
avec des structures avec qui on
travaille encore voilà on pour vous
dresser un petit panel de nos actions
pour illustrer aussi une autre manière
d'intervenir nous avons différents
champs d'action qui sont comme le disait
ma collègue surtout ce continuum qui va
de la prévention de la souffrance mais
aussi à la promotion de la santé mentale
il faut pas oublier aussi de développer
les compétences psychosociales qui
permettent aussi de prévenir la
souffrance en passant par la prise en
charge
on annonce qui s'appelle chez nous les
speed meetings sont des stands de
sensibilisation qui vise à aller à la
rencontre des étudiants de manière assez
informelle idée temps vraiment de lever
les freins va rencontrer un conseiller
de santé mentale parce que c'est vrai
qu'on parle voilà la difficulté
financière ni la difficulté aussi
psychique
quand on va mal on a des difficultés à
solliciter le soin il ya y aller elle
identifie aussi les acteurs avec qui
peuvent nous aider
donc voilà ça c'est un dispositif qui
permet d'aller au plus proche des
étudiants nous avons aussi les pauses
qui sont des ateliers de groupe sur des
thématiques très ciblées de prévention
donc on va travailler sur des choses
comme le sommeil le stress la relaxation
la méthodologie projet et cetera l'idée
étant de mieux outiller les expédients
tout en bénéficiant de l'apport du
groupe puisque du coup ça permet aussi
de bénéficier de l'expérience des uns et
les autres et aussi de créer du lien
social puisque ça a été dit l'isolément
est une problématique étudiante
importance au delà de ces actions de
prévention nous avons donc tout un pool
la diapo précédente même si nous avons
tout un champ de consultations
psychologiques d'accompagnement voilà
psychologique sous deux modalités
différentes
une modalité qui est en présentiel donc
c'est ce qui s'appelle chez nous les
abstient world donc là les consultations
sont implantés directement sur les lieux
de vie et les lieux d'études à des
horaires adaptés typiquement lorsque
nous intervenons en résidence
universitaire nous sommes sur les
horaires de soirée ce soit vraiment très
accessibles et adaptés aux emplois du
temps des étudiants l'idée aussi de
cette implantation sur l'élu lui l'élu
d'études et de casser cet aspect est
stigmatisant d'avoir un lieu de soins
étiquetés comme tels même si c'est
parfois importants et on accompagne
aussi des étudiants faire cette
transition
quand le besoin en est mais en tout cas
voilà d'être au plus proche des
festivités en termes d'accessibilité
géographie financières d'accès à
l'information aussi nous avons aussi une
modalité distant ciel qu'on a mis en
place depuis déjà six ans donc on a créé
il ya six ans de la vidéo consultation
webcam on les étudiants pour répondre
déjà à l'époque à certaines
problématiques tout d'abord la mobilité
étudiante c'est je pense une
problématique au coeur de soins et des
ruptures justement dans le parcours de
soins donc c'est une caractéristique
part du public étudiant
cette mobilité il fallait donc pouvoir y
répondre et c'était une manière
d'apporter ses solutions
nous avons aussi des étudiants qui ont
des emplois du temps très chargé entre
pellet ternant sont pas des jobs
étudiants d emploi du temps aussi
académique extrêmement à la charge et
donc le fait d'être en dix ans ciel avec
des horaires plus souples permettait de
répondre aux besoins et contraintes
aussi de ce public
sans compter les freins d'accès aux
soins qui sont les handicaps physiques
ou psychiques qui peuvent empêcher la
consultation en présentiel donc il nous
paraissait essentiel de pouvoir proposer
cette modalité 1 et dans le contexte de
la crise sanitaire cela nous a permis de
maintenir une continuité des prises en
charges engagées en présentiel sur
l'année donc il n'y a eu aucune rupture
de prise en charge pour les étudiants
nous avons accompagné par ailleurs
depuis six ans notre expertise et notre
expérience de terrain nous montrent que
les prises en charge en lice en ciel
sont tout aussi efficaces que celles en
présentiel sto confirmant si la
littérature sur la téléconsultation
actuellement une autre réaction chez
nous et porte à porte c'est un programme
validé un cas bénéficier d'une recherche
et qui a montré que les interventions
donc sur plus de 4500 étudiants étaient
efficaces pour réduire de manière
significative la dépression la détresse
et le risque suicidaire chez les
étudiants qui en bénéficiaient donc
c'est très spécifique
mais ceci est très corrélée au public
étudiant qui les commet on a dit
particulièrement à risque de ces
troubles la et de risque suicidaire le
coeur des interventions sont menées par
des étudiants qui sont formés de façon
très conséquente et étroitement encadrés
tout au long de leur intervention et
l'internet bat l'osm en l'indiquant
porte à porte pour nous c'est important
aussi quand on parle voilà de prévention
parle aussi beaucoup de prévention par
les pairs c'était très important surtout
dans ces sujets là d'avoir des personnes
qui sont quand même des pères experts on
peut pas se permettre de lancer offrant
des étudiants eux mêmes qui ne seraient
pas suffisamment formés ou accompagnés
par des professionnels
donc là on vous a fait le panel de se
bouffer à destination des étudiants pour
nous ça a été très important dès le
départ aussi de lancer aux
professionnels qui sont premiers
contacts des étudiants on est encore sur
les diapos précédente désolé à tous et
lente du coup on a des modules de
formation à destination des acteurs qui
sont souvent les premiers
radar en fait deux publics peuvent se
retrouver confronté au mal être et ne
pas toujours être suffisamment outillés
pour pouvoir accompagner et orienter les
étudiants que c'est comme ça qu'on tente
sur le mal être
le trauma le suicide tous les acteurs de
la vie étudiante
toutes nos actions dont sur s'inscrivent
finalement en articulation avec les
autres acteurs médico-sociaux dans les
différents territoires nos intervenants
puisque les problématiques des étudiants
sont souvent complexes intriqués où on
doit être une première commande féminin
important qu'on puisse aussi avoir
d'autres relais et vos sources enfin
depuis quelques années maintenant on
voit apparaître de nouveaux
comportements de santé qui sont
l'utilisation d'internet pour trouver
des premières réponses pour s'orienter
vers le soin donc nous avons souhaité
aussi penser un site internet qui est le
site d'aptitude pas comme un véritable
outil de prévention qu'il ya déjà de
nombreux articles sur les différentes
difficultés que peuvent traverser les
étudiants mais aussi déjà des ressources
en ligne qui peuvent s'approprier pour
une première voilà une première aide est
également une partie évaluation où ils
peuvent
voilà avoir une première évaluation de
leur mal-être en ligne et une
orientation vers les aides adaptées
c'était ajoute aussi de certains temps
de penser quand on parle de tout ça de
la présence sur les réseaux sociaux est
aussi là où vos communiqués on trouve le
public étudiant enfin dans notre action
une grande partie de nos psychologues
intervenants sont formés à
l'intervention d'urgence et donc nous
sommes également largement sollicités
par nos partenaires pour intervenir
lorsqu'il ya des événements haute
anciennement traumatique qui surviennent
au sein de structures et juste pour
finir voilà merci beaucoup un petit mot
voilà sur le constat par rapport aux
coville alors c'était largement 10,1
cette idée que bon la crise permet
quelque part de mettre en avant ces
problématiques qui existe déjà de fin
qui existe depuis toujours on voulait
juste souligner au niveau de la
temporalité aussi combien finalement
les confinements et les différentes
phases de cette crise sont aussi des
très corrélée à la ligne de base qui est
très lié au public étudiant c'est à dire
que le premier confinement est arrivé à
un moment de l'année où il faut bien
avoir conscience plus loin mars
normalement un moment où il ya un petit
peu de rechute sur les demandes des
premiers examens sont passés les
étudiants ont pu avoir certaines
validations la fin de l'année approche
ils ont pu se constituer vu le réseau
social
ce qui n'a pas été le cas du deuxième
confinement qui est arrivé à un moment
où finalement on était quand même en
début d'année les étudiants étaient peu
ou pas du tout en présentiel et ça
arrive un moment donné qui est toujours
très difficile j'ai public étudiant qui
est juste après les vacances de la
toussaint jusqu'au vacances d'hiver et
aussi la chute de nombreuses heures de
soleil qui est joue aussi beaucoup sur
les états dépressifs et c'est toujours
un moment où une explosion des demandes
luxe nogent des risques suicidaires et
que c'était alors c'est important aussi
de ne pas oublier que tout ça est aussi
le révélateur comme on a pu le dire
d'une telle souffrance étudiante qui est
déjà distante et qui fonctionne déjà
comme ça depuis quelques semaines on
voit aussi apparaître encore plus une
forme de détresse réactionnelle c'est à
dire ça a été dit là aussi mais des
étudiants qui sans ces crises sanitaires
se réalise bien aimerait bien fonctionné
ce qui était moins qu'il a jusque là où
c'était surtout des troubles qui venait
s'exprimer encore plus fort et plus
massivement mais avec déjà un fils qu au
départ d'être en souffrance de celle de
l'histoire les fonctionnements sa voix
de tous les facteurs qui peuvent amener
à la souffrance des étudiants de manière
générale sur les breuleux matic majeur
là aussi l'importance gagner on n'a pas
eu des normes nouvelles problématiques
c'est surtout voilà l'expression qui a
été beaucoup plus conséquente est
beaucoup plus nombreuses à noter quand
même quelque chose sur les rythmes on a
vu notamment au niveau du premier
paiement d inversion du rythme jour nuit
à ses conséquences avec des trucs du
sommeil très conséquent et on peut lier
aussi au fait d'être en permanence sur
les écrans donc la saâne et des choses
parfois dramatiques l'isolément des
étudiants à nouveau qui est quelque
chose qui est très existant qui est
contre est un peu avec l'image qu'on
peut avoir le public étudiant qu'il a
été renforcée de manière massive
on peut penser notamment à tous les
internationaux on s'était dit c'est
quand même 35 % de la population
étudiante
et cette précarité à la fois sociales
mais aussi financières avec les yankees
perdre leur job qui période leur
alternance parce qu'on a vu apparaître
depuis 2018 si la sonatel gît dans tout
ce qui est cohérent siete là c'est des
choses qu'on a vu effectivement là aussi
augmenter le lien est évident c'est
entre que je monte lema ti keko vite et
puis tout ce qui a trait bien sûr au
projet professionnel à la perte de
motivation elle des étudiants qui
s'interroge pas ce que je vais pouvoir
aboutir mon diplôme je la trouvais de
stage j'ai du mal à me concentrer a
motivé à séné partiel est ce que quand
j'aurai ce diplôme
il aura une valeur quel sera mon
insertion sur ce marché du travail qui
est déjà bien à binic voilà on a essayé
de tenir dans les tendres france a ravi
de répondre à vos questions dans un
second temps voilà merci beaucoup merci
merci à vous vous avez tenu à peu près
dans le dépassement que tout le monde
s'accorde est ici donc donc ça allait je
passe tout de suite la parole à monsieur
morvan je rappelle que vous êtes mode de
combat à l'université de nanterre
également membre du collège scientifique
de l'observatoire de la vie étudiante
j'essaierai d'être synthétique les
messieurs les sénateurs je remercie pour
cette audition je rappelle quelques
chiffres en préambule les étudiants une
population qui compte les données
dossier s nous rappelle que 2,7 millions
d'étudiants sont en son temps ci sont ce
qu'il fait sur d'étudiants en france
qu'il représente d'après l'insee deux
tirs de la classe d'âge entre 18 et 20
ans un tiers de la classe d'âge entre 21
et 24 ans situé les enjeux de santé
mentale le rapport la feuille de route
santé mentale rappelle le coût
économique et social élevé de la santé
mentale 109 milliards d'euros par an
on peut rappeler aussi que les troubles
psychiques sont invalides dont il
représente le 7ème rang en france en
termes de troubles invalidant et le
quatrième rang dans le monde sont des
troubles fréquents
une étude sur l'ensemble de la
population au danemark indique que 15 %
de la population totale a déjà présenté
un trouble à l'âge de 18 ans et ce sont
des troubles qui démarre tôt c'est à
dire que une étude américaine réalisée
en 2005 nous indique que 75 % des
troubles des buts avant l'âge de 24 ans
don constitue déjà les enjeux en termes
de santé mentale et en termes de santé
mentale étudiante
donc quel indicateur de quels
indicateurs disposons-nous avant la
crise peu d'indicateurs fiables
disponibles
alors pourquoi fiable parce que peu
d'indicateurs à l'échelle nationale
l'échantillon représentatif
peu de données fines avec des questions
de croisement de données par exemple de
donner à kalemie qu'est-ce que les deux
les la question de la santé mentale
impacté les trajectoires de vie d'un
point de vue académique l'impact des
conditions sociales et donc je pense je
cite le rapport récemment rendu sur la
politique publique de la donner un qui
pose cette question tant qu en tant que
membre de du collège scientifique de
l'observatoire de pouvoir effectivement
en tant qu'institution publique de
pouvoir travailler avec les autres
organismes et croiser les données
bien sûr dans le respect et un gp des
droits des personnes c'est une évidence
mais en tout cas de pouvoir décloisonner
l'information pour obtenir une donnée
film pour renseigner la politique
publique et aider au mieux les étudiants
peu d' études longitudinales une
question importante est ce que les
choses se sont aggravées
mais encore il ya très peu d'études
longitudinale disponibles il ya la
cohorte ishare qui existe qui est une
source de données importantes mais à
part ça il ya les données de l'ové eux
on essaie de mettre en place un suivi
longitudinal et donc là
l'enquète ville et union confiné est un
recontacte longitudinal donc ça nous
permet de destiny un certain nombre de
choses mais il y en a pas suffisamment
et donc je n'irai avant là avant la
crise en 2016 c'est tout l'intérêt de la
première enquête santé des étudiants ont
été réalisées par l'observatoire de la
vie étudiante qui s'est calqué en fait
sur l' enquête du baromètre santé des
français pour pouvoir avoir des éléments
de comparaison population étudiante
population j'ai quelques chiffres de
cette enquête puisque effectivement la
situation était déjà difficile à
l'époque 15 % d'étudiants présenté un
épisode dépressif majeur contre 10% de
la population générale
alors avec un élément réduire
concordance et que dans nos remettre
santé les français vous aviez déjà 13%
des répondants en situation d'études qui
déclarent un épisode dépressif majeur
pour condé suivre je suis une donnée qui
se confirme on avait un recours aux
soins pour les étudiants dans l'année
qui présentait des troubles dépressifs
qui était de seulement de près de 53%
contre 60 8 % dans le baromètre santé
les français n'ont qu'un regret soins
qui était beaucoup plus faible et
surtout un recours aux professionnels de
santé mentale ou à des thérapies
adéquate c'est à dire soit
médicamenteuse de type anti dépresseurs
soit les psychothérapies qui était
seulement présente pour un quart d'entre
eux dont karl kraus homme qui était déjà
très faible en 2016 et puis la question
de l'idéation suicidaire qui était déjà
à 8 4% contre 4 7% qu'en population
générale
à l'époque alors depuis la crise il y a
eu un certain nombre d'études et il faut
les saluer l'étude de deux en picardie
les setu dossier de l'université de
lorraine mais ce qu'est ce qui est
compliqué c'est que les indicateurs en
santé mentale sont difficiles parce
qu'il ya déjà plein d'indicateurs
différent il ya plein d'outils
différents et pour un décideur politique
c'est vrai que vous voyez vous êtes
confrontés à des chiffres si on regarde
sur fait la synthèse des données qui
sont qui sont produites sur uniquement
la dépression où vous avez une
information qui varie en indiquant qu'
entre 16 et 43 % des étudiants qui
souffrent de dépression concours et la
variabilité leur s explique pas parce
que c'est des méthodes différentes c'est
des outils de mesures différentes c'est
les taux de participation différentes et
des seuils pour définir ce qui est un
trouble qui est différent donc c'est un
petit peu un petit peu difficile à
comprendre et donc quelles données pour
quelle décision mais ça veut pas dire
que la situation n'est pas réel la
situation est réelle et l'ensemble des
indicateurs nous pointe effectivement
une augmentation des difficultés des
difficultés psychiques des étudiants en
général mais aussi de la population
de la population dans son ensemble alors
comment ont traduit ces données en
termes interventionnelle et je rejoins
les collègues
ce sont des données importantes parce
que c'est 210 nm et des données au
niveau officiel populationnelle les
donnait en moyenne et ce sont des
données qui regroupe des situations
extrêmement hétérogène c'est une
photographie à un instant t de situation
dynamique qui évolue ce sont des
phénomènes en mouvement ce qui amène de
plus en plus en tant que scientifique je
vais pointer mais ce qui a déjà été dit
à modéliser les troupes comme des
systèmes complexes en équilibre
s'appellera mon voisin qui est physicien
effectivement des phénomènes massivement
massivement complexe et aussi
massivement multi factorielle ça a été
rappelé et une intrication deux
composantes complexe environnemental
social et économique
l'académie interpersonnelles un train
individuel biologique cognitives et
narrative j'insiste sur ce point parce
qu'on a beaucoup évoqué la question du
suicide et il est extrêmement important
de rappeler que dans le contexte actuel
qui est effectivement difficile de
d'inquiétude vis-à-vis de l'avenir de
situations d'isolement de rappeler
l'importance de programmes comme le
programme programme papageno il faut
rappeler des des histoires positives
dire que oui la situation est difficile
oui les étudiants souffrent mais il y a
une devenir possible
il y à une sortie de la crise possible
si bien évidemment reçoit de l'aide
voilà il faut insister sur cet élément
parce que la difficulté c'est qu'on
nourrit aussi nous même dans nos
discours des scénarios qui amène à une
situation plus difficile n
représentation de sa propre situation
plus difficile alors les collègues de
l'observatoire de la vie étudiante l'ont
rappelé un les effets de la crise sur
les conditions de vie et d'études une
vision d'avenir assombri termes
d'insertion professionnelle c'était
aussi rappelé par par monsieur le
président a parlé collègues un coup
d'arrêt porté à certaines activités
rémunérées des difficultés financières
perçues comme plus importante
et puis l'augmentation de la détresse
psychologique qui a augmenté de 20% à
30% les chiffres diffèrent mais parce
que les seuils et les méthodologies
diffèrent mais taux de réponse diffère
ce qui explique en fait
ces différences de chiffres et puis un
non recours aux médecins lorsqu'ils en
avaient besoin
plus particulièrement pour les étudiants
les étudiants détresse alors quelle
intervention pour pour les étudiants la
clé une des clés en tout cas qu'ils
aient trouvé dans la littérature c'est
bien évidemment les stratégies de
prévention cr sensibiliser mais détecté
tôt et intervenir tôt c'est éviter que
la situation de transition vers un
trouble puisque ce sont des systèmes
complexes en équilibre instable
sire que ça se déstabilise dans une
situation pathologique parce que une
fois que le système aider à changer
d'état parfois il faut mettre beaucoup
plus d'effort ou d'énergie pour revenir
à un système antérieur d'efforts de
soins donc effectivement il vaut mieux
intervenir tôt pour éviter une
transition dans le des états les
facteurs de risque
évidemment les études nous aide à
identifier les facteurs de risque des
populations cibles sur lesquels il
convient de il convient peut-être
d'intervenir mais attention ce sont des
stratégies niveau global derrière il
faut les instances y ait de manière
individuelle cirque il ne s'agit pas de
dire on a identifié que les étudiants en
lettres et sciences humaines ou en 3e
année ou en première année à tel endroit
sont plus en souffrance et mais qu'est
ce qu'on leur propose derrière encore
encore une fois communiquer ses excès
sensibiliser c'est extrêmement important
mais proposer une réponse et une réponse
rapide qui ne sera pas trois mois six
mois de délais d'attentes où on vous a
sensibilisé on a fait le travail et
c'est tant mieux
non le travail ne fait que débuter donc
une nécessité d'une évaluation clinique
par des professionnels pour pouvoir
distinguer les situations et les degrés
de sévérité qui varie dans le temps il
faut proposer une réponse graduée
adapter une réponse rapide et surtout
une réponse soutenu dans le temps
pour que les six parce que les
situations évoluent elles bougent les
systèmes bouge
la situation des étudiants bouge les
professionnels ont besoin d'un temps
dédié maximale auprès de ces personnes
ça a été évoqué pour les questions de
réseau les cliniciens ont besoin de
temps ils ont ils ont besoin de deux de
soutien pour organiser la prise en
charge et la chaîne de soins
donc c'est des éléments extrêmement
importants et ça nécessite de coordonner
les niveaux d'intervention donc le rôle
essentiel des acteurs des acteurs
associatifs ça a été sous-traitée noté
je pense einstein je pense aussi et si
tu dis je pense aux premiers secours en
santé mentale les étudiants relais mais
il faut faciliter derrière cet aspect là
les parcours entre prévention évaluation
prise en charge et suivi donc différents
acteurs différentes structures
différentes tutelles et un article
récent publié publié sur une
modélisation alors on fait attention
c'est un modèle en australie indiqué qu'
effectivement sont des programmes
multiples avec une amélioration de du
lien social
des systèmes qui permettent de
coordonner les soins à l'aide de
technologies de systèmes d'information
un suivi un suivi au long cours des
personnes après leur crise et des
actions de réduction des des difficultés
sociales durant l'enfance et une
augmentation des programmes d'emploi et
des aides sociales pour les étudiants
pouvaient permettre de réduire d'à peu
près 30% mais c'est encore une fois un
modèle les comportements suicidaires
donc quelles solutions pour les
étudiants
faut rappeler le rapport de la cour des
comptes qui nous dit que le constat
principal sur une offre de soins
diverses peu graduée est insuffisamment
coordonnées et que les moyens
spécialisés extrêmement important
gratuits sont souvent asphyxié faute
d'être concentré sur des publics
prioritaires et évidemment faute de
moyens donc effectivement beaucoup de
choses se font on a parlé du shape si ça
va dans le bon sens mais encore faut-il
que ça s'implémente de manière cohérente
avec les dispositifs existants et que ça
vienne en interaction et non pas en
empilement en se disant voilà on a créé
quelque chose de plus on répond à un
besoin
certes il y as besoin si c'est peut-être
pas suffisant évidemment la plupart des
données nous disent que c'est plutôt de
l'ordre de 20 séances dans la
littérature mais c'est déjà ça
on va c'est mieux que rien mais derrière
il faut aussi pouvoir coordonner sa et
organiser ça donc réponse graduée et
coordonnée je dis rien de plus que ce
qui est dans le rapport de la cour des
comptes
évidemment une logique de territoire
l'exemple du réseau respect est un
excellent exemple
merci c'est pas ici qu'on peut parler
des territoires c'est pourquoi en parler
mais il faut donner il faut pouvoir
donner les moyens assez assez assez ces
réseaux qui se mettre en place qui se
met en place pardonnez moi de pouvoir
fonctionner mais aussi de répondre à des
situations extrêmement hétérogène et la
même manière on parle ici du réseau
respect sur la région parisienne mais
peut-être que le réseau respect à une
logique sur le territoire parisien qui
sera pas la même logique sur un autre
territoire
là encore donc ça dépend des situations
hétérogènes et effectivement donné les
moyens de cette coordination de cette
organisation au niveau des projets
territoriaux de santé mentale ça paraît
une évidence et là aussi une fiche
action
là encore dans le pts m du 75 sur les
étudiants qu'il faut aussi souligner
c'est un exemple et peut-être c'est un
exemple qu'il faut qu'il faut reproduire
le rôle central et pivot de la médecine
préventive universitaire dans cet aspect
de coordination évidemment mais elle a
besoin de moyens pour cela elle a besoin
d'outils
il faut imaginer
est ce que c'est que parfois des
services de médecine universitaire qui
n'ont pas les outils ne serait-ce que
numérique d'organisation de deux de
leurs missions
il faut pouvoir faciliter c'est c'est le
fonctionnement des services le plus
possible je parle par exemple des
aménagements d'études
les amendes et les aménagements d'études
occultes dans le cadre la prise en
compensation du handicap qui est
évidemment nécessaire utile et qu'il
faut soutenir mais qui va occuper une
place importante de leurs consultations
donc puisque il ya une augmentation ces
dernières années donc tout c'est tous
ces aspects la chaîne organisationnelle
du soin de la prise en charge des
compensations académiques sont à sont à
faciliter pour les services pour qu'ils
puissent consacrer du temps aux
étudiants au niveau peut-être plus +
nationale effectivement développer les
systèmes de prévention s'appuyer sur le
numérique l'agent santé du numérique là
aussi fait fait un travail très
intéressant il faut développer les
outils ya de plus en plus de de deux
systèmes qui se développe à l'aide de
deux smartphones pour pouvoir essayer de
d'identifier de répondre rapidement de
de favoriser l'orientation mai mais là
encore il faut que ça s'implémente dans
quelque chose de réel il faut pas croire
que c'est une simple applis en tant que
soit ne fait ne fait rien si elle n'est
pas suivie d'une action si elle n'est
pas suivie d'un professionnel derrière
et je suis d'accord avec les collègues
les les système de visio fonctionne la
littérature nous confirme que des prises
en charge numérique fonctionne aussi
bien mais souvent c'est qu'il faut un
humain derrière c'est à dire que si vous
avez des systèmes qui sont totalement
automatisés avec par exemple déjà lire
des fiches pratiques et cetera houleux
où l'étudiant va suivre quelque chose
ils sont une acceptabilité moindre et le
système devient moins efficace donc
l'usagé des nouvelles technologies
il ya même une
un projet qui était financée par un
chercheur pour un chercheur à
l'université de genève le chercheur sa
peine avec le fric qu'ils aient reçu un
rc starting rennes justement pour
essayer d'utiliser ces technologies
smartphones sur la base de modélisation
complexe pour essayer de prédire la
transition et d'intervenir au plus tôt
voilà j'en ai fini pour mon intervention
merci beaucoup monsieur morvan sus
cannes c'est à vous tant que vous êtes
le le dernier voilà à vous exprimer
essayer d'être quoi d'être aussi très
synthétique pour qu'on puisse échanger
ensuite ensemble
elle hésite et de ma limité à 45 minutes
à peu près comme vous voulez que c'est
parfait du coup je vais présenter
brièvement l'association et puis un peu
notre regard sur cette situation et puis
une étude qu'on avait qu'on avait fait 6
qui peut vous intéresser
donc night line est une association
étudiante qui travaillent sur la
question de la santé mentale étudiante
depuis 2016 avec le soutien d'une équipe
de salariés de professionnels des
communications et de et de santé mentale
notre projet phare c'est des services
d'écouté paris pour des étudiants qui se
décline sur des territoires actuellement
on est présent à paris à lyon à lille à
saclay et à partir du mois prochain à
toulouse aussi
ce sont des étudiants formés
sélectionnés et soutenu dans un cadre
éthique très rugueux développé depuis
une cinquantaine d'années dans les pays
où sexe pays anglo saxons pour assurer
que les étudiants qui s'impliquent dans
ce type de démarche
le font d'une manière qui est qui est
saine pour ces étudiants
c'est une démarche de prudence donc le
message qu'on essaie de faire passer
auprès des étudiants c'est que si vous
nous contactez du coup par téléphone ou
par chat le soir c'est avec un autre
étudiant que vous allez parler et
l'autre messages clés qu'on essaie de
faire passer c'est que il n'y a pas de
mauvaises raisons de nous appeler
si vous êtes en train c'est ce qu'on
disait que c'était dans les amphis de
rentrer mais si vous êtes en train de
rentrer du cinéma le soir et vous voulez
parler du film vous pouvez très bien
nous appeler pour ça l'objectif c'était
de rendre la démarche de parler de ses
difficultés avec quelqu'un aussi facile
que possible pour permettre aux
étudiants de s'exprimer au moment le
plus tôt de la détresse dans l'espoir
que cette expression pour les aider à
trouver une solution donc ça pourrait
être parlé avec un nuit par les
vêtements de la famille simplement
parler parfois ça peut être très utile
et puis on joue un rôle important dans
l'orientation vers des des services
professionnels
quelque chose qu'on avait vu très vite
c'était que c'était très difficile pour
les étudiants qui nous contactent de
trouver le bon professionnel il
connaissait pas forcément les réseaux
existants et nous du coup on jouait le
rôle d'interlocuteur de tremplin vers le
bon service procès étudiants donc on vu
en dix pour cent des personnes qui nous
appellent
on mène aussi d'autres actions notamment
des actions de prévention co construite
avec des étudiants le premier étant un
site qui s'appelle soutien aux étudiants
pour info qui recense l'ensemble des
soutiens psychologiques disponibles sur
le territoire
c'était un travail qu'on avait réalisé
pendant lés prises anita parce qu'on
s'est dit que pendant cette période là
où les modalités d'accès en changer
rapidement
il fallait que ce soit facile pour les
étudiants de trouver le bon service ce
site a été utilisée par plus que 80
mille personnes pendant la crise donc je
pense que ça prouvait sur l'utilité
on mène aussi des campagnes de
prévention notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux
instagram plus particulièrement parce
que c'est là où se trouvent les jeunes
juste à la fin de l'année civile on
avait mené une grosse campagne avec des
influences art parce qu'on s'est dit que
ça c'était une façon de toucher une
population non sensibilisés à la
question de la santé mentale pour faire
passer un message simple si vous n'allez
pas bien il faut en parler avec
quelqu'un que ce soit en ami au nom de
la famille en professionnel et puis on
les orienter dans ce site soutient
étudiants pour qu'ils puissent trouver
en cas de besoin un soutien
professionnel
cette campagne toucher plus que 2
million de jeunes sur le territoire
entre 18 et 24 ans on est aussi en train
de préparer des projets de père et non
sur les campus parce qu'on a une demande
récurrente de la part des belliot
notamment les bureaux des élèves parce
qu'ils se retrouvent souvent face des
étudiants discutent et ils savent pas
quoi faire
nous on peut pas leur donner la
formation nightline parce que c'est un
cadre éthique qui est construit dans un
cadre où on est anonymous est à distance
il faut construire autre chose pour
assurer que la en application ce soit
saine et enfin on mène aussi des actions
sur les campus quand c'est possible et
ça c'est quelque chose qui va monter en
charge à partir de l'année prochaine
je pense que d'autres termes en vend
très bien souligné que c'était un
problème avant la crise
la problématique de la santé mentale
étudiante new notre première année
d'ouverture donc c'était l'année 2017
2018 on avait 200 contacts donc c'était
un début en douceur
l'année d'après donc c'était avant la
crise sanitaire c'était 1600 l'année
dernière c'était 3200 cette année on va
dépasser très facilement 7500 contact de
la part des étudiants en difficulté du
coup nous on voyait qu'ils avaient une
augmentation importante même avant la
crise sanitaire est quelque chose qui
est extrêmement important à souligner
c'est que cette crise de santé mentale
étudiante n'a pas commencé avec la crise
qu vide on a commencé à en parler
grâce à cette crise
il faut absolument pas qu'on les oublie
par la suite je pense que quelque chose
qui est intéressant c'est un peu nos
constats face cette crise on avait
regardé un peu comment d'autres pays ont
réagi face à la crise la santé mentale
étudiante est une des premières choses
qu'on avait identifiées c'est qu'il n'y
a pas de stratégie de santé mentale
étudiante en france
je compare notamment avec la grande
bretagne qui en 2015 avec la première
recommandation de politiques et
procédures pour la santé mentale
étudiantes qui ont été publiés au niveau
national en 2018 un cadre national a été
créé en 2019 une charte de santé mentale
et union universitaire a été créé le
cadre national était mis à jour en 2020
si on regarde le canada en guide prend
le proche s'estimer systémique à la
santé mentale profondeur été publiés en
2013 et puis des normes sur la santé
mentale et bien-être pour les étudiants
du cloud secondeur a été publiée par la
commission de la santé mentale du canada
en 2020 en irlande en 2017 il y avait un
rapport du task force nationale sur la
santé mentale des jeunes et en 2020 un
cadre national sur la santé mentale
étudiante la prévention du suicide et
union on n'a pas de stratégie comme ça
en france et on l'a vu les effets d'un
manque de stratégie quand la crise coded
est arrivé et quand les choses sont
devenues très compliquées pour les
étudiants à qui il faut toucher
il ya un autre point qui est un très
important pour nous c'est que tu les
étudiants sont concernés par cette crise
de santé mentale étudiante
on a une tendance à vouloir focaliser
sur des groupes avec des problématiques
spécifiques
ils ont des problématiques spécifiques
qui ont besoin d'être reconnus je pense
notamment aux étudiants internationaux
qui sont dans une situation très
compliquée les étudiants en santé
mais c'est l'ensemble des étudiants de
toutes les filières de toutes les
classes sociales qui sont touchés il
faut une réponse qui répond à l'ensemble
des étudiants
il faut aussi une réponse qui répondent
aux étudiants non universitaires
[Musique]